- [Voiceover] g is a function
that describes an arithmetic sequence.
Here are the first few
terms of the sequence.
So let's say the first term is four,
second term is 3 4/5,
third term is 3 3/5,
fourth term is 3 2/5.
Find the values of the
missing parameters A and B
in the following recursive
definition of the sequence.
So they say the nth term
is going to be equal to A
if n is equal to one
and it's going to be
equal to g of n minus one
plus B if n is greater than one.
And so I encourage you to pause this video
and see if you could figure out
what A and B are going to be.
Well, the first one to figure out,
A is actually pretty straightforward.
If n is equal to one,
if n is equal to one,
the first term when n equals one is four.
So A is equal to four.
So we could write this as g of n
is equal to four
if n is equal to one.
And now let's think about the second line.
The second line is interesting.
It's saying it's going to be
equal to the previous term,
g of n minus one.
This means the n minus oneth term, plus B,
will give you the nth term.
Let's just think about what's happening
with this arithmetic sequence.
When I go from the first
term to the second term,
what have I done?
Looks like I have subtracted 1/5,
so minus 1/5,
and then it's an arithmetic sequence
so I should subtract or add
the same amount to every time,
and I am, I'm subtracting 1/5,
and so I am subtracting 1/5.
And so one way to think about it,
if we were to go the other way,
we could say, for example, that g of four
is equal to g of three
minus 1/5,
minus 1/5.
You see that right over here.
g of three is this.
You subtract 1/5, you get g of four.
You see that right over there
and of course I could have written this
like g of four
is equal to g of four
minus one minus 1/5.
So if you look at this way,
you could see that if I'm
trying to find the nth term,
it's gonna be the n minus oneth term
plus negative 1/5,
so B is negative 1/5.
Once again, if I'm trying
to find the fourth term,
if n is equal to four,
I'm not gonna use this first case
'cause this has to be for n equals one,
so if n equals four, I
would use the second case,
so then it would be g of four minus one,
it would be g of three minus 1/5.
And so we could say g of n
is equal to g of n minus one,
so the term right before that minus 1/5
if n is greater than one.
But for the sake of this problem,
we see that A is equal to four
and B is equal to negative 1/5.